Ahora complicamos las cosas un poco más: en el
lado izquierdo de la balanza no sólo tenemos
estas tres masas misteriosas idénticas
marcadas con una equis en color azul,
sino que también tenemos algunas de las masas
de un kilogramo aquí, en realidad tenemos dos de
ellas. Ahora queremos averiguar a qué equivale x.
Pero antes de que hagamos eso quiero que pienses
en una ecuación matemática que represente lo que
está sucediendo aquí, que lo que está en el lado
izquierdo es equivalente a lo que está en el lado
derecho de la balanza. Te daré unos segundos para
que pienses en ello. Pensemos en lo que está en
el lado izquierdo: tenemos tres masas x, entonces
puedes decir que tenemos 3x, y luego tenemos dos
masas de un kilogramo, entonces en total tenemos 2
kilogramos, esto es + 2; por lo que una forma de
pensar en la masa total en el lado izquierdo es
3x + 2, tres masas con masa x más dos kilogramos,
eso es lo que tenemos en el lado izquierdo. Ahora
pensemos en lo que tenemos en el lado derecho,
podemos simplemente contarlos: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 14 bloques, cada
uno tiene una masa de 1 kilogramo, por lo que la
masa total será de 14 kilogramos; y vemos que la
balanza está equilibrada, sin inclinarse hacia un
lado o hacia el otro, entonces esta masa de aquí
debe ser igual a esta masa de acá. La balanza está
equilibrada, por lo que podemos escribir aquí un
signo igual. Ahora quiero que pensemos en algunas
cosas, y puedes hacerlo ya sea con la ayuda de
los símbolos o de una balanza: ¿cómo te desharías
primero de estos dos pequeños bloques de 1
kilogramo? Te daré un segundo para que lo pienses.
Bueno, lo más simple es quitar estos bloques de
1 kilogramo del lado izquierdo, pero recuerda:
si simplemente quitas estos bloques, y antes
estaba equilibrado, ahora el lado izquierdo
será más ligero y se moverá hacia arriba, pero
queremos mantener la balanza equilibrada para que
esto siga siendo igual, que esta masa sea igual
a esa masa. Entonces, si quitamos dos bloques del
lado izquierdo, necesitamos quitar dos del lado
derecho, entonces podemos quitar dos de aquí y
luego podemos quitar dos de acá. Matemáticamente
lo que estamos haciendo es restamos 2 kilogramos
de cada lado, estamos restando dos de este
lado así que en el lado izquierdo ahora tenemos
3x + 2 - 2, nos quedamos con sólo 3x, y en el
lado derecho tenemos 14 y quitamos 2 -déjame
escribir esto-, quitamos 2, así que nos vamos
a quedar con 12 bloques. Y si cuentas aquí los
que no he tachado son 12 y aquí tienes 3 de estos
bloques con masa x. Dado que eliminamos la misma
cantidad de ambos lados, nuestra balanza aún
está equilibrada y nuestra ecuación queda 3x
ahora es igual a 12. Ahora, este es un problema
muy similar al que vimos en el último video,
entonces les pregunto: ¿qué podemos hacer para
aislar una x, para tener sólo una x en el lado
izquierdo de la balanza, manteniendo la balanza
equilibrada? La forma más fácil de pensarlo es
que si quiero una x en este lado izquierdo,
esto equivale a 1/3 del total de x aquí,
entonces ¿qué pasaría si tuviera que multiplicar
el lado izquierdo por 1/3? Si quiero mantener la
balanza equilibrada tengo que multiplicar el lado
derecho por 1/3, si hacemos eso matemáticamente,
aquí puedo multiplicar el lado izquierdo por
1/3, y si quiero mantener mi balanza equilibrada
también tengo que multiplicar el lado derecho
por 1/3, multiplicarlo físicamente en realidad
significa sólo mantener 1/3 de lo que teníamos en
un principio, nos desharíamos de dos de estos. Si
queremos mantener 1/3 de lo que teníamos aquí
originalmente, quedan 12 bloques después de
quitar los dos primeros, entonces 1/3 de 12 sólo
nos quedarán cuatro de estas pequeñas cajas de 1
kilogramo. Déjame eliminar todos menos cuatro:
entonces quito estos y estos, y he dejado 1, 2,
3, 4 aquí, y así lo único que te queda es esta
x. La sombrearé para mostrar que esta es la que
realmente nos queda. Y luego tenemos estas cajas
de 1 kilogramo, lo puedes ver matemáticamente
aquí: (1/3) 3x o podría haber dicho 3x ÷ 3, de
cualquier manera esto nos da: estos 3 se cancelan
por lo que quedará una x, y en el lado derecho
12 (1/3), que es lo mismo que 12/3 = 4. Y como
hicimos lo mismo en ambos lados, la balanza aún
está equilibrada, entonces puedes ver que la masa
de este bloque debe ser la misma que la masa de
estos cuatro bloques sobrantes: x = 4 kilogramos.